ça s'appelle les lacs c'est une des
petites crêpes en géant avec des patates
et on le mange pendant la fête de
hanouka est juif qui dure huit jours
j'ai la recette de ma grand mère et
enfant pastel easy peut-être raconter
l'accueil très facile à faire mais en
général c'est très facile
cette épatante avec des oignons rapide
avec un peu de farine et
de mon côté ça le deviendra pas voudra
parts avec un peu de sel et poivre c'est
tout c'est pas compliqué mais c'est très
bon on les mange avec de campo ta pomme
normalement et de yogourt ou de crème
sure c'est quand on l'appelle comme ça
alain clerc est elle venait de là on
broie la hongrie
la hongrie est venue de la hongrie est
un mais elle est venue aux états unis
quand elle avait 9 ans les juifs qui
venait de les robes de la ce jeu j'ai
l'impression qu'ils ont beaucoup de
recettes avec la farine le sel les
patates des foires du fromage comme des
recettes vraiment pas compliqué parce
qu'ils ont mais ils ont pas eu beaucoup
d'argent ou des aliments avec acquise et
quiz pour moi les la casse est vraiment
la tradition c'est la famille c'est être
ensemble pendant l'hiver c'est soit d'or
mais on est dans la cuisine tout
ensemble on allume les chandelles man
aura pour le traducteur et on est tous
ensemble et c'est vraiment des bons
souvenirs que j'ai de mon enfance et je
continue ça avec ma famille
aujourd'hui et demain la seule que j'ai
de ma grand mère elle est utilisée
seulement les patates rouge à mais aussi
il ya des gens qui dit sommes non
seulement des patins doré mais moi
j'utilise ça c'est des patates
biologique que je reçois d'une interview
que je connais ou alors s'ils sont très
petites
alors c'est plus de travail pour les
jeunes et oui mais mais salue très très
bien mais on va déraper et ça aussi
c'est important on les rate rarement car
même avec comme à la messe je le ferai à
la main forte dans le queens à brasser
une secret et ça fait une grande
différence
merci c'est tout d'abord même l'oignon
en levant la main au secret
le matin c'est qu'une fois qu'il s'en
fait et on le met dans un ton moins ya
moins de l'eau dans la facette et c5
mieux je mets le nez dans le temps de
lavabos pendant plusieurs heures les
attaques ultra moderne comme ça avec
site côté mais j'ai celle là et ça ça
appartenait à mon autre mode de l utérus
elle m'a donné quelque chose quelques
petits trucs de sa maison alors j'ai ça
j'ai fait ça aussi
oui ok ravanas à 1 et j'ai sept vols ah
ok je pense que ça c'est comme ça c'est
tout c'est tout ce qu'il lui doit elle
utilise l arast pourquoi faire quoi de
l'abkhazie
de la quinzaine probablement plus le
bois ça c'est une soupe avec fait avec
deux choux et l'étonnante c'est une race
et de russes aussi très très simple tout
en angles et ouais c'est ça marche très
très bien ouais ok maintenant tu vas
faire l'oignon et bien tu vois c'est
très juteux et six avaient fait les
patates dans le cuisinant ça serait
vraiment commune pas une forme 700 alors
que les enfants pensent que cette fois
qui fait les meilleurs la caisse où est
le bon dieu est bon jamais le dire aux
gens attendent en vente aujourd'hui que
c'est très bon les autres acteurs mais a
fait vraiment bon